alja's been working for the past three
years only get better he's gotten better
since those Peter John fights Corey
sander Hagin fights TJ dillashall he's
getting better every single he's in his
prime so I think this was not the case
of Henry sudo being older I think it's
the case of how good Al Joe is and you
guys need to recognize that but this
isn't going to do it I knew this wasn't
gonna do it the fan base was not gonna
give him his credit so now he's gonna
get sugar Shawn which is actually a more
favorable matchup than any of the Hutto
that won't do it shooter has no
wrestling so I don't know what it's
going to take for aljo to step up and
fight at 145 and fight volkanovsky so if
he beats volkanoski will that satisfy
you guys does he have to do that does he
have to beat volkanovsky in order to get
your respect it's crazy to me crazy